woman definitely we are having
intensified influx of migrants primarily
from the direction Macedonia actually
thousands of migrants are crossing a
Serbian Macedonian border every day at
one moment few nights ago we had seven
thousand people crossing the border and
that reason for that reason the react we
reacted promptly and timely I would say
so we established a reception center at
the very border with Macedonia in the
town of rochewell and the EM Daily
influx the moment is 2000 to 200 2500
people every day actually they are
coming to Serbia not to seek asylum in
reality but to to cross Serbia actually
Serbia is and was and I believe it will
be on the transit destination
destination from for migrants from Asia
and Africa so at the moment I would say
that the Republic of Serbia is really
competent and can cope with a
intensified influx of migrants of
migrants yes what you say that mr. miss
Kavita you say that it may always be a
transit country for the migrants but
what if Hungary decides to completely
closed its border two thousand more
police will be installed by September
helicopters horses dogs and of course
this fence all designed to stop the
influx of refugees well in my belief
it's impossible to stop desperate people
so if they decided to escape from there
from there war war torn countries in a
search for a better life for a decent
life it's impossible to stop them we saw
many fences in the history we saw some
fences and walls in recent history but
no results so we believed it will be it
will be impossible to stop them but even
if that's what
stops them they will find another route
another way at the moment we are
witnessing this so-called Balkans route
so they come from from Greece to
Macedonia then to Serbia then to Hungary
but very soon maybe they will change the
route and maybe they will be heading
Croatia actually it will be a bit more
difficult to them because they will they
will be forced to pass one state border
more because you there is still a border
between Croatia and Slovenia but I
really believe that will be it will be
impossible to stop them this is
something inevitable at the moment